ranging from funny to festive these
holiday favorites are just waiting for
you to binge at your leisure and
whenever you get started it will be the
most wonderful time of the year here's a
look at the best Christmas movies on
Netflix if you're a bit of a Christmas
cynic you could always spike your eggnog
and sit down with Bad Santa a comedy
about a man who uses one of the seasons
most enduring symbols to gain the trust
of everyone around him and then rob them
blind while also getting blackout drunk
sure it might seem a little
mean-spirited but Bad Santa is actually
part of a grand tradition of Christmas
films including the beloved classic It's
a Wonderful Life that used misfortune
and misery as entry points into
discovering the true meaning of the
season in this case the person who needs
to discover it is Willy soaked played by
Billy Bob Thornton a safecracker who's
sick of his life masquerading as a mall
Santa when he meets a naive but
good-natured boy named Thurman Willy
finds his life slowly beginning to take
on meaning again whether he really wants
it to or not it's unapologetically
foul-mouthed then surprisingly joyous by
the end and features a terrific
supporting cast that includes the late
John Ritter and Bernie Mac Plus if
you're having fun with Bad Santa Netflix
can always carry you right over to the
sequel Bad Santa - in the years since
Love Actually was released it is divided
viewers with the hottest Christmas media
debate since baby it's cold outside
set in the month leading up to Christmas
it has a cast of well basically every
British actor you've ever heard of
including Alan Rickman Hugh Grant Keira
Knightley Liam Neeson mr. bean Bilbo
Baggins and Rick from The Walking Dead
thanks to its interweaving stories of
love it's been called the ultimate
romantic comedy and embraced as a
holiday essential by many while
dismissed as an overwrought mess by
others who think it has some pretty
dubious ideas about romance it's a
debate we still have every Christmas but
after all that dust settles we still
want to watch it every single year some
viewers may dismiss a Christmas Prince
as another generic royal romantic comedy
that the filmmakers just slapped some
Christmas decorations on if you actually
sit down and watch it though you'll find
charm hearts and a story that rings
every little bit of joy out of what is
given to work with rose McIver stars as
a young reporter eager to catch the eye
of her boss by infiltrating the ad lobby
and monarchy and learning what's keeping
the mysterious Prince Richard from
claiming his rightful place on the
throne
after going undercover as a tutor to the
princes young sister surprise she
quickly falls in love with Richard only
to find that there are enemies out to
stop his coronation on Christmas Eve
it's not the most lavish production
you'll ever see
but there's a reason Netflix dropped the
sequel this year here's hoping it
becomes an annual tradition with
increasingly ridiculous plots Santa
buddy's is a warm little movie perfect
for kids who love cute dogs and holiday
cheer the story revolves around puppy
paws the son of Santa's dog Santa Paws
because of course that's his name who's
a bit worn out by Christmas and just
wants to be a normal puppy maybe you
should be thinking about how important
Christmas is to children and puppies all
around the world puppy paws leaves the
North Pole and tries to learn how to be
a regular puppy from a few who happen to
be on Santa's naughty list
what puppy paws doesn't know though is
that the very fate of Christmas hinges
on him learning a lesson about the true
spirit of the holiday and he'd better
learn it fast before the cold-hearted
dog catcher played by Christopher Lloyd
can ruin everything in other words it's
the exact plot of elf but with an
adorable puppy instead of will ferrell
believe it or not though it's both
adorable and weird enough to be
watchable the only real problem was
showing it to your kids is that they
might decide a puppy is the one thing
they want for christmas yet Santa is yet
another film that follows a recognizable
holiday formula this time it's the tale
of the young child trying to convince a
cynical adult that Santa Claus is real
the twist is that gasps Santa takes that
premise and mixes it up with a kinder
gentler version of a Guy Ritchie crime
comedy and the results are as strange as
they are delightful Rafe spall stars as
Steve a former getaway driver fresh out
of prison and eager to reconnect with
his son Tom tom is a bit disinterested
but calls his father for help when he
believes he's found Santa inside a shed
hello May how are you how are you doing
well this Santa claims that his sleigh
crashed and his reindeer have been
scattered and asks for help only to end
up locked in prison instead with
Christmas on the line it's up to Steve
and Tom to find the reindeer and list
the help of some elves and get Santa
that is if Steve can ever find his way
to believing in father Christmas again
it's a wonderfully weird little movie
with a new twist on a classic tale plus
a version of the journey to the North
Pole or
sidious it's called in the film you've
likely never seen before if you're after
an enduring Holiday Classic full of
musical numbers gorgeous Technicolor
imagery and the exquisite comic timing
of Danny Kaye then white Christmas is
for you I want you to have nine children
and if you only spend five minutes a day
with each kid that's 45 minutes and I'd
at least have time to go out and get a
massage or something like many holiday
films of its time it doesn't entirely
revolve around Christmas but rather
builds to it by telling the story of
four entertainers who find themselves at
an inn in Vermont only to find that
December hasn't brought any snow with it
yet like the characters the audience
waits virtually the entire film for
anything wintery or Christmasy to show
up but when it finally does it proves to
be absolutely worth it in addition to
Kay's comedic mastery the film also
features being Crosby in one of his most
famous roles Rosemary Clooney showing
both her acting and singing chops Vera
Allen's incredible dancing and some of
the most memorable musical numbers
you'll ever see oh and there's also a
pretty good song in there you might have
heard of this film has lived on in the
hearts of Christmas movie fans for more
than 60 years and a single viewing is
all it takes to understand why Netflix
isn't just excelling in the fairytale
princess Christmas rom-com department
they've also branched out into more
humble even somewhat quirky offerings
aimed at everyone who enjoys cozy low
stakes Christmas fare enter the holiday
calendar the story of a small-town
photographers stuck in a rut both
personally and professionally her life
seems to be going nowhere until her
grandfather gives her an antique advent
calendar that once belonged to relate
grandmother those are predicting the
future
[Music]
how much wine have you had tonight the
calendar will only open its doors on its
own magically at midnight each night in
December revealing a unique charm that
will prove to have some meaning in her
life the following day through the
calendars magic Abby thinks she finds
love then realizes there are bigger
lessons to be learned from this strange
little family artifact the Christmas
calendar like so many Christmas romantic
comedies is ultimately predictable but
its charm is such that you won't really
care if you see the ending coming
sometimes the most casually enjoyable
Christmas movies arrive when you take a
tried-and-true romantic comedy formula
and just sprinkle a little Holly and
mistletoe through it all that's the case
with Christmas wedding planner the film
follows wedding planner Kelsey as she
attempts to plan and execute the perfect
holiday wedding her biggest problem
isn't the venue or the bride but a
private investigator who's threatening
to expose the truth about the couple at
the heart of the ceremony and wreck the
whole wedding you expect me to believe
that some mysterious person hired you to
ruin this wedding well technically
looking at time but during the wedding's
a potential outcome in an effort to keep
the pie happy while still delivering the
dream wedding she was hired for Kelsey
agrees to join his case and help him get
to the bottom of it of course if you
know romantic comedies at all you can
probably guess what happens next
after a long day of shopping this is
exactly the kind of light crowd-pleasing
holiday fare to throw on while you're
wrapping presents dear Santa is one of
the best known and most beloved of the
21st century's large crop of made-for-tv
Christmas romances that frequently
circulate on lifetime paul mark and now
netflix it's a growing sub-genre and a
steady rotation for many fans and dear
Santa is a big reason why amy acker
plays Krystal a rich girl who's facing
the threat of being cut off by her
parents if she doesn't find some sense
of direction when she stumbles upon a
letter a little girl wrote to Santa
asking for a new wife for her widowed
soup kitchen running father Krystal
takes it as a sign that she's meant to
be a part of their family of course not
all goes according to plan an injury
thing I just happened
Netflix devotion to original programming
led to an even bigger holiday movie boom
in 2018 than we've seen in previous
years and that may have reached its peak
with the Christmas Chronicles a film
that blends a little bit of the Santa
Clause a little bit of found-footage and
a whole lot of Kurt Russell into a very
enjoyable package the film follows a
pair of children whose family has been
devastated by loss as they try to get
along together on Christmas Eve when
young Cate believes she spotted Santa in
an old family home movie she persuades
her brother Teddy to stay up with her
for a stakeout one thing leads to
another and the siblings find themselves
face-to-face with the real Santa Claus
who's very different than decades of
marketing have made him out to be no
need to wake up early there won't be any
presence you two are on the naughty list
for life with little time and a lot of
frustration the trio has no choice but
to team up find Santa's Lost belongings
and save Christmas
it's exactly the kind of charming romp
you'd expect from the producer of the
Harry Potter movies and a director who
worked on frozen and wreck-it Ralph only
weirder